a three billion pound warship the pride
of the royal navy
but for most of today hms prince of
wales was stranded off the south coast
[Music]
this was the vessel's celebratory
departure on saturday delayed by a day
due to a technical issue
it was then supposed to spend three
months traveling to new york canada and
the caribbean conducting training
exercises with the navy's western
atlantic counterparts
this uh deployment to the western
atlantic is designed to reinforce our
relationship with the united states
they're going to embark f-35
aircraft from both united states and the
uk
we're also going to start practicing
using drones especially in ukraine and
the ability to use drones from the
aircraft carrier and at sea more
generally is part of the next stage of
fifth generation warfare in which the
royal navy is currently engaged and we
need the ship as a trials platform to
make sure they work and we can use them
operationally
shortly after its departure the vessel
stopped there are reports that there's
damage to the ship's starboard propeller
shaft but all the ministry of defense
said was that the vessel had faced an
emerging mechanical issue
we're about five miles off the coast and
there she is a 65 000 ton warship the
hms prince of wales is one of the navy's
most prized vessels and now in need of
repair
it's always embarrassing when one of
your major fleet units breaks down
i don't think
we know the extent of what has happened
yet as
i think we've seen it may be a major or
a minor fault
we don't like our warships coming out of
the front line if you like to be
rectified
several smaller boats appear to be
involved in the vessels returned to a
different anchorage where the navy says
further inspections can take place
sardia chowdhury sky news on the isle of
wight